[Música]
de muchas formas
la más común hoy en día
son nuestros aparatos electrónicos
la computadora los ipad y en especial
estas cajitas mágicas los celulares
hemos tenido o hemos creado
una dependencia total con ellos en ellos
tenemos todos nuestros contactos todas
nuestras fotos la buena y las malas
tenemos nuestro horario nuestras cuentas
bancarias
la fecha de nacimiento de la tía de la
abuela inclusive tenemos en estas
cajitas mágicas la fecha en que tenemos
que llevar ácido a vacunar al
veterinario
pero a la misma vez está no pueden hacer
la vida más fácil
no tenemos que recordar el teléfono de
nadie y aquí todo está simplemente hay
que apretar un botón
lo que también viene con esta cajita
mágica son las redes las redes sociales
todo mundo la conoce facebook twitter
instagram
y un montón y cada día hay más más y más
que nos mantienen conectados
de una buena forma con nuestra familia
con nuestros amigos con grupos de
conocidos e inclusive con grupos de
desconocidos
y hay veces que terminamos en
situaciones que no sabemos cómo llegamos
ahí
discutiendo de algo que está pasando del
otro lado del mundo con una persona que
vive del otro lado del mundo y ninguna
de las dos sabemos de qué estamos
discutiendo
pero yo quiero hablar de otro tipo de
conexión
conexión con las montañas con esos
titanes de hielo roca y de vez en cuando
un manto de niebla
esa conexión que es directa
esa condición que no necesitamos reuters
no necesitamos password y es una
conexión única
y cada persona puede tener una diferente
mi nombre es karim ella soy montañista y
mi pasión es la montaña
mi pasión de la montaña empezó a la edad
de 11 años
subiendo nuestro querido pico duarte
para mí en esa época era simplemente una
experiencia
de ir a dormir a un campamento en una
fogata bañarme en un río estar con los
amigos
pero desde esa época me di cuenta que
esas expediciones al pico duarte a las
alturas era un poco diferente
a esas esos juegos que yo hacía cuando
era pequeño con mis amigos y salíamos de
una excursión atrás de la casa había
algo diferente
era la altura era el frío no se era la
lejanía con la familia
pero eso siguió
a la edad de 15 años yo realicé mi
primera excursión solo
yo me fui al monte de jarabacoa
yo solo ya yo había estado ahí
anteriormente
como parte de una excursión pero esta
vez fui solo
recuerdo recuerdo muy vivamente esa
excursión
yo llegué en la tardecita a la cima yo
hice mi tienda de campaña con un poncho
militar y utilicé una frazada verde en
una estructura de ramas de matas de
guayaba y estaba lloviendo o sea que
inmediatamente yo entré a la tienda a
esperar oa quedarme ahí
recuerdo mi escena fue una lata de leche
boiardi y unos pasitos que se vendían en
en jarabacoa
como era mi primera vez solitario en la
cima de una montaña yo no pude dormir
y en la noche es campo y yo dije déjame
salir a ver que lo que hay afuera cuando
yo salí yo me sorprendí de ver este mar
de estrellas
y allá a lo lejos veía un contorno de
luces que era el pueblo de jarabacoa las
faldas de él
del mogote
en ese momento fue muy extraño para mí
ya que yo sentía
conexión con todo lo que estaba a mi
alrededor
una afinidad que yo no podía explicar
el olor de la grama mojada
el frío que hacía la brisa
lo sentía interiormente
pero a la misma vez
todo lo que representaba ese contorno de
luces que era el pueblo de jarabacoa
para mí era totalmente extraño
era casi surreal eso estaba ahí pero no
estaba ahí
entonces en ese momento yo me empecé a
dar cuenta
de lo que es conectarse con la
naturaleza y con el ambiente en que yo
estoy
y desconectarse de todo eso que uno trae
consigo
entonces yo le voy a enseñar algunas
fotos para que ustedes entiendan el
porqué debemos desconectarnos de vez en
cuando
si nosotros no nos desconectamos de lo
que nosotros vivimos el día a día cuando
nosotros vamos a la montaña
nos va a ser muy difícil entrar
en un sentimiento directo con lo que
esos representan
o con el sonido el frío del agua del río
es diferente si uno está pensando en la
capital o está pensando en su casa o en
su pueblo que si uno está concentrado en
lo que está haciendo en esa naturaleza
y uno lo siente completamente
también
y este tipo de excursiones uno se
encuentra con personas similares a uno
que están utilizando la misma conexión
que ya mencioné
esa conexión con la naturaleza y esa
conversación entre un excursionista y
otro son diferentes a las conversaciones
que tendríamos aquí
ya que serían más cortas porque entre
conversación y conversación permiso
allá no hay nada de eso es totalmente
abierto
entonces yo siempre
he deseado pasarme tiempo en la montaña
escalar nuevas rutas escalar nueva
montaña ir a nuevos lugares
y para mí cada montaña es diferente
inclusive la misma montaña
cada vez que uno va a un viaje es
diferente una experiencia totalmente
diferente
y tenemos que estar totalmente libre
de cualquier situación externa para
poder disfrutar
hay momentos en que si no nos
concentramos en lo que estamos en la
montaña perdemos la oportunidad una
oportunidad que no va a regresar
y oído el pico duarte perdí la cuenta y
cada viaje es diferente y si yo pierdo
una oportunidad de ver el sol de ver un
amanecer un atardecer en un viaje ya eso
no lo puedo recuperar ya se perdió
y puedo ir al otro año puedo volver pero
es diferente
y ahí es que tenemos que
sentarnos a pensar si yo estoy aquí para
disfrutar esta naturaleza porque yo
tengo que estar conectado a otra cosa
ya a otro nivel cuando hablamos de
montañas altas
ya eso de conectarse y desconectarse
tiene otro sentido
tenemos que dedicar toda nuestra
atención a lo que estamos haciendo
porque eso significaría la vida o la
muerte
si nosotros estamos escalando un lugar
peligroso
o cruzando los bases del combo hay sol
tenemos que estar 100% en sintonía con
nuestro medio ambiente
en ese caso son los pre bases y los
cielos del con wise
algo interesante cuando uno sube el
everest específicamente los lugares más
difíciles y estar con nuestros sherpas
ellos cambian totalmente su actitud
ellos son
le gusta hablar son siempre sonrientes
pero cuando entramos al combo hay sol
ellos se callan prestan atención y tiene
los ojos bien grandes
están conectados al hielo porque un
lugar peligroso y al mínimo de sonido
inmediatamente yo levantan la cabeza y
miran para aquí y para allá
y eso es estar conectado
mi primer viaje al everest yo lo veía
mi segundo viaje libres yo lo vivía
y estuve conectado igual que ellos
y en varios momentos
yo me preocupe que se hubiera ido por
primera vez si no hubiera estado en
sintonía con lo que el hielo estaba
diciendo no me hubiera preocupado
pero yo sabía lo que estaba diciendo el
hielo se estaba moviendo
los cera que se estaban cayendo flotando
otra razón por la que debemos abrirnos a
esa conexión con la naturaleza y por lo
puro que es todo allá lo puro que es el
aire
lo puro que es la tierra lo puro que es
el cielo
y más que todo lo puro que nosotros nos
sentimos allá
personalmente
en la montaña
yo creo y veo que sale lo que uno
realmente es
no hay forma de enmascarar lo
usted es usted
y por más que usted quiera no puede
cambiarlo
porque no hay distracción
muchas de las imágenes que tenemos en
nuestra mente cuando hacemos algo
interesante no solamente montaña
alguien tiene un hobby muchas de esas
imágenes siempre se quedan con nosotros
en este caso ese sol imponente esos
compañeros de escalada
son cosas que se quedan con uno
y sobreviven
cuando regresamos a casa regresamos a
nuestra vida cotidiana
no podemos perder eso aunque nos
desconectamos tenemos que mantener esa
esencia esas cosas que nos van a hacer
cambiar que nos hacen feliz
que nos levantan el ánimo
por eso es importante desconectarse
para conectarse con algo nuevo
con algo revitalizador
este una foto del cubo hay sol
cuando tome esta foto
nosotros estamos parados esperando que
ese grupo terminara de subir esa parte
porque si lo ven
ahí no será que están a punto de caer
pero pasan por ahí una vez y la próxima
vez esa ruta no existía
no importa la hora del día
que estemos cuando estamos haciendo algo
que es nuestra pasión pues el día noche
madrugada como quiera siempre uno lo
encuentra esa belleza siempre uno le
encuentra eso que le llega a uno
y tenemos que aprovecharlo
las oportunidades hay que aprovecharla
porque cuando se pierden muchas veces no
vuelven y las experiencias más cuando
perdemos esa experiencia
y se fueron
y después nos pasamos el resto de
nuestras vidas dándonos la cabeza
caramba porque no lo hice caramba porque
en ese caramba porque no fui allá
para mí la altura es algo mágico
me hace sentir de una forma libre
y me hace sentir que nosotros no somos
lo que creemos que somos
mucha gente se cree que es lo máximo
mucha gente se cree que es muy grande
mucha gente se cree que la última coca
cola del desierto como se dice
pero realmente cuando uno está allá
y no se da cuenta de que uno es
y si somos así vamos a tratar de hacerlo
mejor y sacar lo mejor de nuestro tiempo
hay veces que nosotros estamos un
ambiente tóxico y nos mantenemos ahí
porque tenemos miedo de perder esa ese
es el link ese contacto
nos vamos a quedar atrás
tengo que ver lo del chat porque si no
no me voy a enterar
ha mencionado varias veces el miedo a
hacer algo nuevo
y a eso yo me refiero
cuando sintamos algo que queremos hacer
no lo dejemos para después
vamos a hacerlo vamos a disfrutarlo al
máximo porque puede ser el último
momento la última oportunidad para
hacerlo
cuando yo fui al everest por primera vez
con el año 2011
uno de los compañeros de nosotros
norteamericanos rick hoyts él perdió la
vida entre el campamento 2 y el
campamento 3 en el lhotse face
su compañero de escalada y vamos por
grupo su compañero de tienda
me pide
desconectarse de ese evento de esa
situación y tuvo que abandonar
y cuando yo hablo de algo tóxico esas
son las cosas que tenemos que ponerlo a
un lado si queremos continuar y llegar a
una meta
cuando nosotros llegamos en la primera
expedición al everest llegamos al
campamento 4 lo primero que vimos fue a
un alpinista japonés el cuerpo de un
alpinista japonés que lo venían bajando
se fue el recibimiento del campamento 4
y si nosotros no hubiéramos puesto esa
situación a un lado y mantenernos
enfocados en lo que estábamos haciendo
no hubiéramos llegado a la cima
en mi segunda escalada al everest que
fue este año
fue un poco más interesante
el clima estaba más malo el hielo estaba
muchísimo peor
y hubieron muchas fatalidades
aparte de que la ruta no se ha limpiado
de cuerpos en los últimos 67 años
entonces fue bastante intenso
el caminar el subir el tratar de llegar
a esa meta cuando uno veía todas
todas todos estos obstáculos
que trataban de desconectarnos de
desenfocarnos de lo que queríamos hacer
y ahí es que tenemos que hacer más
fuerte y luchar
siempre mantenernos mantener nuestra
visión en esa meta
pero yo
digo que fue por ese enfoque que gracias
a dios pude llegar a la cima por la
segunda vez y ese enfoque sirvió no sólo
a mí
sirvió para algo más
sirvió para llevar la bandera por
segunda vez a la cima del monte everest
en ese momento no había otra bandera más
alta que la dominicana cuando estábamos
cuando yo estaba en la cima ya
y yo
pienso que eso es simplemente por
mantener el enfoque y esa conexión
directa con algo que yo estaba haciendo
entonces al final decimos qué hacemos
con ese enfoque después que ya logramos
algo ya nos desconectamos nos vamos para
casa y nos olvidamos de todo porque ya
ya hemos ganado algo vamos a utilizarlo
vamos a compartir esa experiencia vamos
a pasar esa experiencia para otros
y todos podemos hacerlo
porque siempre hay algo más siempre más
me preguntan ya tú súbete al ebro 9 para
que tú quieres otra vez voy a tu cita de
ver dos veces que más hay hay muchas
cosas más
una de ellas es compartir
compartir esa conexión directa que me
llevó a compartirla con otros
y para eso yo he utilizado la fundación
siempre más
que junto con un grupo de voluntarios
nosotros compartimos esas experiencias y
tratamos de tener una conexión directa
con jóvenes
la gente joven es de nuestros barrios
jóvenes que no tienen la capacidad o
tienen la
el chance de conocer nuestra montaña de
conocer esa cima el punto más alto de
las antillas
así que con eso quiero dejar y decirle
qué
enfóquense y conectarse con sus pasiones
para que lleguen a donde quieran llegar
gracias